when you do a sponsorship deal with
somebody you have to look deep into who
they are and you know who's running the
company who's making the decisions and
are you aligned yeah I love that man
yeah because we had Robert Kennedy Jr on
and we had a company call a couple
companies call after that and say yeah
just stuff about them we're not
advertising on this episode my
advertisers like you guys need to take
the episode Down you know and uh and and
we ended up and what's wrong with him
nothing nothing
guy's [__] brilliant guy's a smart
[__] guy for seven years great guy I
mean a neat man right I I've never met
him yeah I've only watched his stuff and
and you got this whole Democrat
Republican [__] all this crazy
[__] he's a [__] Democrat yeah
right but now they hate him just because
he doesn't believe like he's a Democrat
with common sense right yeah right he's
like an old school Democrat yeah and
smart guy whatever let me tell you this
let me [__] tell you
this this is
America you can [__] have whoever you
want on your podcast you can do whatever
the [__] you want to do imagine a
sponsor that's sponsoring you calling
you and telling you that you can't have
this guy what sponsor did it
um I let me think and I'm not afraid to
name him I don't know if I remember I
really don't right I don't know if I
believe you but okay that's fair
but I really don't know if I remember oh
pelaton was the we just got an update um
P was the B with the people who wanted
an ad out pelaton and meanwhile you have
RFK so pelaton yeah what do they sell
[__] bik the stationary bikes yeah
pellaton sell stationary bikes and they
got a problem with Robert [__]
Kennedy [__] you pelaton what who the
[__] are they yeah first of right are
you [__] kidding me yeah yeah [__]
pelaton calling bitching about Robert
Kennedy yeah dude you want to go nowhere
who who's the CEO of
pelaton I want to see this [__] I
want to see this [__] lamb dude hey
you know what gets you further than
pelaton hitchhiking okay how about that
dude Barry mcy this [__] weener
snitel let's see Barry McCarthy oh my
god oh
oh yeah oh [__] yeah Barry McCarthy
looks like that guy 100% and look if
you're just listening at home and you're
thinking of what he looks like you're
right he looks like a douchebag yeah
dude 100% where's he from oh yeah he
looks like somebody that eats his own
skin a little bit at a time yeah he is
he is
a where is he [__] you called me up
and said this guy was complaining about
something I'd say oh
[__] San Francisco California there we
go my boy ring a ling dude they've been
giving pelaton to [__] vagrant that's
why they're not leaving yeah [__] you
pelaton yeah do we have pelons in the
gym are those
pelaton asport no no there's bikes next
to it asort as yeah we're getting rid of
them yeah we're getting rid of the
pelons yeah and if they ever we sorry
he's going to kill himself but we're
getting rid of the pelons look pel are
out of the gym whoever uses the most can
[__] have them at home but they can't
use them here brother that's what you do
that that's what you do you stop [__]
using their products and you [__] them
yeah and tell them to go [__] themselves
and that's the same thing for me like if
somebody's telling you that you can't
vote a certain way if somebody's telling
you that if your bosses make a video and
[__] blast imagine that [__] dork
yeah [__] picking up the phone
calling you and telling you that you
can't have Robert Kennedy who is a
Democrat by the way you know that guy's
a [__] Democrat right telling you
that you can't [__] have him on your
show who the [__] are you Barry McCarthy
yeah to think you can pick up the phone
and call anybody you sell [__]
stationary bikes for a living you
[__] clown [__] you yeah [__] damn
dude god dude and what is he [__]
what is he he's probably middleweight
I'll [__] cut 40 pounds in [__]
that guy is the typical [__] pompous
arrogant [__] douchebag that I cannot
stomach it's people who don't yeah it's
people that think they know what it's
like somewhere and they've never even
been there it's a story of a lot of our
country these days but I like this it
gives me it gives me an Avenue to feel
like I can fight back so I appreciate
that you have to fight back yeah you're
gonna let that [__] guy tell you what
to do [__] no dude I will cook that
dude's [__] look at this there he is
that that right there tells you exactly
what [__] Barry McCarthy is all about
pelaton just laid off 500 of their
employees in their fourth round of cuts
this year y you know what everybody
listening [__] [__] Barry McCarthy
and pelaton okay that that's what a
standup guy Barry is yeah dude and
that's why he a yeah [__] no SL off
let off 500 more of his [__]
employees out and his fourth round of
cuts yeah and what's Lamer than watching
your husband get on a bike that doesn't
go anywhere
huh what wife is like oh I'm so proud of
this guy that's like my dad man right my
uh get borsari in here right now I need
borsari in here yeah get him yeah is he
a bicyclist he has to be if he isn't why
does he look exactly's he's just he's a
workout freak I'm I'm not bullshitting
you you can film us yeah my my guys are
going to take the pelons out of the gym
today I love that dude we're getting rid
of them we're going to go throw them in
the [__] garbage today I'll be happy
to toss him in we're throwing pelons and
the garbages we're throwing them out of
the UFC Gym all right so this is Craig
borsari he's my head of production Craig
he's friends with my my I know his
neighbors yep there you go oh he's CRA
Craig is very friendly with all hisb an
exceptional guy so uh he was in a
situation where he had Robert Kennedy uh
Jr on his show and an Advertiser called
and told him get rid of that you're not
posting that podcast take it down blah
blah blah because he had Robert Kennedy
on right um it was
pelaton okay well do you know who Barry
McCarthy is Barry McCarthy is the CEO of
pelaton yeah let let us see Barry
McCarthy again can we see him again
please we got pictures of you and Barry
McCarthy together actually Craig is that
is that pelons that we have in the gym
we have pelons yeah they're going we're
throwing them out yeah getting rid of
them that's Barry McCarthy be on a
treadmill this is the [__] guy that
called and told him to take down the the
the [__] we had an episode does that
look like the guy that would call him
[__] about Robert Kennedy Jr he does
doesn't he who is that [__] like Tim
Cook
yeah he does huh little I don't know who
Tim Cook I mean I'm just agreeing with
you um I don't know him either who's Tim
Cook he look oh oh Apple okay so peles
are gone they're gone they're going out
today I got to go bike on the road now
yeah yeah something no you you just got
to use the assault bikes now instead
yeah huh those are tougher anyway really
way tougher Pon it's time to step up if
I if I asked you to guess so he called
and he wanted Robert Kennedy Jr taken
down mhm right
threatening him uh on his podcast right
yeah they were about to go public I
think their company was about to go
public or something they're like this
could ruin everything that's what our Ad
Agency said to us they're worried this
could ruin everything it's [__] 8:00
at night on a Friday or something can
you [__] imagine that uh and they
made us go take an O older episode down
because of something he' said in
recently in the news or this was like a
year and a two years ago maybe where
where do you think Barry lives where do
you think he's from just look at him
guess H and and listen to the
conversation and see if you can tell me
where Barry lives yeah he probably lives
let me
Craig San Francisco oh [__] ding ding
ding ding ding dude hey you just Barry
lives in San Francisco hold on you just
won four
pelons congrats you just won a whole
[__] line of you can line them right
up in your house can't set them up here
in the office so I might as well put
them on my home those are going right in
your house congrats I'll put them in my
garage have a flock of pelons dude isn't
that a band you're can have a flock of
pelons dude that's classic man oh man um
all right anyway just had to share that
with you yeah I go figure out my new
workout go get those bikes sent over to
your house yeah dude and send Barry a
text and tell him thanks thanks dude
that makes you feel empowered honestly n
this is what I do I I like it to do more
of this what I do every day bik helmets
either anybody wearing a [__] bike
helmet out there I bet you Barry wears a
helmet when he rides his oh I bet he
wears when he rides his wife
dude you [__] come around me with a
bike helmet dude I would rather get a
concussion and die and be seen in a
[__] bike Helm so that is
awesome